تحطمت طائرة ركاب صينية على متنها 132 شخصًا
في جنوب الصين ،
أكد مسؤولون طيران حكوميون
أن طائرة تابعة لخطوط طيران شرق الصين
سقطت في الجبال في جنوب شرق الصين
، وستعيش معنا ريبلي ، حيث
ستتحول التفاصيل
العاجلة إلى الأسوأ في الصين.
كارثة جوية في عقد من الزمان على الأقل
ربما أطول ، ومن دلالات
خطورة ذلك أن الرئيس الصيني
شي جينبينغ قد أصدر للتو
بيانًا يدعو إلى إجراء
تحقيق كامل معربًا عن تعازيه
وإرسال فرق الإنقاذ إلى هذه المنطقة هذا
أه وقع هذا الحادث في  منطقة غوانغشي
أه إنها منطقة جبلية ، يمكنك مشاهدة
مقاطع الفيديو هذه التي يتم مشاركتها على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الصينية ، كما ذكرت أيضًا
في وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الصينية رؤية
أعمدة الدخان هذه تتصاعد من أه
من التلال هناك أه وأيضًا أه على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يمكنك سماعها  انفجارات في
الخلفية لذلك عندما يكون لديك 123
راكبًا وتسعة من أفراد الطاقم
وعمود من الدخان بهذا الضخامة في متر
منطقة نافورة أه يمكنك فقط أه تخيل ما
قد يجده رجال الإنقاذ عندما
يقتربون من مكان الحادث وهي
منطقة يصعب الوصول إليها حيث يمكنك
رؤية التضاريس التي تغطيها غابات كثيفة
، لم تتعرض الصين لتحطم طائرة
مميتة منذ ذلك الحين  عام 2010 عندما توفي 44 شخصًا
عندما خرجت طائرة ركاب من
المدرج أه تعرضوا لعدد كبير من
الحوادث في التسعينيات ، ربما تتذكرون ذلك ولكن
في العشرين عامًا الماضية أو نحو ذلك ،
حسنت الصين بالفعل سجل الأمان في
السماء بسبب المزيد  إجراءات
صارمة لمراقبة الحركة الجوية وأيضًا
أسطول طائرات شاب إلى حد كبير ، لذا إذا
كان هذا التحطم سيئًا بالفعل كما
يبدو في هذه المرحلة ، فهذه صفقة كبيرة
في الصين ، وقد قامت شركة
طيران شرق الصين بتحويل
موقعها الإلكتروني إلى اللون الأسود  والأبيض اعتبارًا من هذه
الساعة أه بالرغم من عدم وجود
بيان رسمي منشور على موقعهم الإلكتروني
أبيض وأسود بالتأكيد مؤشر على
أن الأخبار في الساعات القادمة قد تكون
سيئة للغاية جون